go and delete all these Y values see
these guys just clear them off okay
unsurprisingly your graph disappears
because you just got rid of all the data
okay but now we can create a new
quadratic equation if I want to do x
squared minus 2x plus 5 what would be
the first thing I do I want the x value
how do I get an x value yeah take the
take that actual cell there right what I
do with this how do I square it
yep use the hat there's x squared
there's x squared and then I minus 2
do I just click the cell now no I have
to multiply it I have to multiply
there's 2 X and then I finish with plus
wait really
yeah 35 okay
so I'm gonna copy that guy I'm gonna
cost I'm gonna paste okay they just like
tada video ok so you can see because we
did all that extra legwork setting
things up like getting all the equations
right getting the data there sitting up
our trendline now you can sort of
effortlessly go ahead you can tell me as
well what's the lowest what's the
minimum value it's gonna be full yeah
it's gonna be 4 ok not all questions
will ask you for a minimum value for
instance if I just muck around with it
like so bear with me thank you
that's that's very generous
you tried that's okay
[Music]
oh I see that's what I want
let's do that that'll do
aha there we go okay
oh yeah the hashtags I can fix that
sorry hashtags there we go okay
so I'm not going to tell you too much
about what's happening behind here but I
just want you to look at what's going on
okay what happened instead of having a
positive value out in front of x-squared
like positive 2 or positive 1 you see
there's a 1 hiding here it's just kind
of sneaky right at that if you have a
negative number at the front you get
this kind of treble you get a this is a
fountain isn't it ok so you're not going
to get asked the minimum value for this
right why not why isn't why isn't
negative 20 the minimum value yeah if I
just extended the table over to 6 and so
on I'm you can go lower and lower and
lower so what question would you get
asked for this what's the highest what's
the maximum value of this okay so you
have to pay attention to what kind of
shape you get and what kind of question
you get asked ok